everyone a very warm greeting to one and
all
my name is srikari Krishna Kumar and I
would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on chem informatics for
biomedical drug discovery
this program is designed to address the
challenges associated with understanding
modeling screening and applying chem
informatics strategies to improve drug
Discovery results the process of finding
a new drug against a chosen Target for a
particular disease usually involves High
throughput screening where in large
libraries of chemicals are tested for
their ability to modify the target with
contributions from leading researchers
in Academia and biotechnology
pharmaceutical industry as well as
experts from the software industry this
comprehensive Mentor guided training
program explains how chem informatic and
enhances drug discovery
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop E-Series analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omix logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization track that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science or biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to the
ominous resources but how does it help
Advance by informatics teaching omic's
logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear part of the Bloom's
taxonomy pyramid and no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bandmatics is omic's logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python even beginning a data
analysis project
this also comes with an access to the
ohmic storage courses which includes
course on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multiomics that includes
genomics transformics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
using RN Titan as well as
cheminformatics and example projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work
users will also be given reactions to
access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multionics
platform
so now to view the various courses you
need to first sign up on the omics logic
learn portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
linked to your social media handles
as well as a brief bio about yourself
that will consist about your educational
background and research
and the mentors can view your progress
under the activity Tab and the courses
you are currently completing will appear
under the courses tab finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the omix logic
loan portal before we proceed ahead with
today's webinar
I am sharing the link for signing up on
the portal in the chat box
so that everyone can sign up
so for those participants who are new to
the portal and who do not have an
account on the portal yet please click
on the create an account option that you
see here and please enter your name
email ID and password and you'll be good
to go with setting up the profile or you
also have an option to sign up using any
of your social media handles that
includes your Google Facebook Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
and with that I'll pause for a couple of
seconds for the participants to sign up
on the portal once you have signed up on
the portal please put a yes in the chat
box so that I know I can proceed ahead
and I'll show you the various courses
and example projects that are there on
the portal
the fee structure of the program and
other program details will be discussed
as we go along so for now let us sign up
on the portal first
once you have signed up you can leave a
yes in the chat box and I'll show you
the various courses that are there on
the photo
so we have one yes I'm waiting for rest
of the participants as well
all right so we do have a couple of
yeses for those participants who already
have an account on the portal you can
simply click on the login now option
that you see here and click on sign in
so once you sign in you'll be able to
see the various courses that are there
on the portal so you can simply enter
the keyword or the course uh topic that
you're interested to work on so for
instance let's say you're in invest in
chem informatics you can simply enter
the keyword chem informatics and that
will show up in course associated with
it so before we proceed ahead let me
briefly demonstrate how you can set up
your profile you can simply click on the
tab that says welcome back with your
email ID and once you click here you
will see I know an icon that says
profile you can simply click on that and
that will show you the various options
to edit your profile image your bio your
name as link to your social media
handles
and under the activity tab the community
manager and the program Mentor will be
tracking your learning progress and the
courses you are currently completing as
I mentioned in my slides will appear
under the courses Tab and once you
complete a project and upload it to all
the portal it will appear under the
project staff finally when you enroll
for the program such as the chem
informatics program that will be
displayed under the programs tab here
as well as the certificates in API under
the certificates
so if the participants have no further
queries let's move on to the next
exciting part of today's webinar wherein
we are joined by Dr puneet Tucker for an
expert talk Dr Kaka is a drug Discovery
scientist and a digital Healthcare
Enthusiast he has a PHD in drug
Discovery from Italian Institute of
Technology from Genova Italy and with
several years of experience in serving
clients coming from Human drug Discovery
veterinary medicine and agrochemical
settings Dr kakar is a strong advocator
for using advanced technology in
pharmaceutical research and development
and with that brief introduction now I'd
like to pass on the stage to Dr Pune
Tucker who will also be the program
Mentor for the chem informatics drug
Discovery so the stage is all yours
thank you very much
and welcome to everybody
um happy New Year first of all
and since we are beginning with this
cheminformatics size and the
kind of a training program educational
program I see a lot of birthdays in the
uh in this year as well as in the
upcoming years in the area of drug
Discovery and development since there's
a significant penetration in the area of
Technology embarking into the process of
Life Sciences and Pharmaceutical
um last couple of years have been very
much evident about how sooner the drug
discovery
should be done rather than this regular
routine exercise of taking 15 years of
time
we have seen the covet penetration how
the human life got impacted how many
valuable lives have been sacrificed with
the infection
and we have seen the power of vaccine
the medicine how
urgently it was required
and the impact of vaccinations is also
very much seen that
um how it could be a life-saving if it
is developed earlier
not just only the covet as a scenario as
an example there are so many numerous
unmet medical needs are in front of us
where drug Discovery is urgently
required where new Therapeutics are
generally required where Innovative
medicines are are required
without the help of Technology it would
be very difficult to meet that
requirement in a such a shorter time
we believe the incorporation of
artificial intelligence machine learning
and Advanced Technologies even the
Technologies which are not very much
directly evident for example
they
machine learning based GPT uh chat Bots
are
a a method a technology incorporation
where it can help to search a very large
data set or connect the entities of
pharmaceutical interest together in a
meaningful way
that retrieve a suitable information
that scientist is looking for a
successful drug Discovery can be so much
beneficial
sometimes think these things are not
very much clear or which are not
directly seen by the people who are into
the early stage of their career
in this particular training program
will not only go through the
traditional ways of
using the technology
in identification of the initial or hit
molecules called
hit identification the identification of
chemical compounds that can become a
suitable candidate for the lead as and
eventually as a drug
but also look at a different perspective
how these technology
things should be seen from the angle of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
in every aspect
right from the beginning of searching a
database
we need to see how we can
automate such processes so that the
larger number screening more
customizable most customized fashion the
data can be retrieved
how you can make the workflows automated
in a way that it should accelerate the
process of drug discovery not completely
end to end the automation order
Discovery but at least some part of that
process
can be automated there are several ways
several Outlook to look at the same
thing in different ways
we will cover those things also in the
exercises that we will be doing in this
educational series
we'll start with some of the
basic databases the content of the
databases and how you interpret the data
in the search publicly available
databases
the very good thing in those publicly
available data sources that they are
freely available
freely available to serve the mankind
freely available so that you can you
should have no boundaries
no boxing in the
in the in the thinking that there are
limitations in your in your mind to
develop a new medicines
the data sets are high quality they are
validated they are available to
everybody there is no restriction of how
much you can download there's no
restriction of is stopping anybody to
use these data set
so publicly available data sets will go
through will understand their files will
understand their processes will
understand how differently you can
utilize those datasets
we'll go to the basic and simple
we had very powerful traditional methods
of drug Discovery utilizing those
individual set of data sets many times
we can we can do fancy stuff but it's
difficult to understand the underlying
concept of how we are using it why are
we using this
is there any best way out of there is
there any alternative advanced
technology way there are there ways
where certain methods will be replaced
in the future for example protein
modeling the traditional ways of protein
modeling have been replaced completely
replaced
by the artificial intelligence method
now
thanking someone doing PhD work in
molecular modeling would be very rare I
would say very rare or maybe requiring a
very very complex study that is required
to be done in a PhD work
but uh
most of the times the structures are
either available the key structures or
if they are not available they are
available by means of alpha 4 or
3D structure prediction predicted by the
artificial intelligence method
we'll go through some of the complex
methods and Technologies for example
molecular Docking Day screening chemical
similarities search screening right
um
so these these screening methods are
very simple but very powerful now you
need to see the same data set can be
done with the help of machine learning
and artificial intelligence where you
can apply what are the opportunities
what are the challenges
every technology every method developed
in the past or currently or they will be
developing in the future they will
always have the limitations and
opportunities
so we need to always balance out the
things when to use which method what is
the ideal way to do that what is more
demanding in here in your
in the in the global scenarios in terms
of career objectives future career
um Ambitions and what are the areas
where the employability is high that
also we will look into some of the
details so overall this training program
this educational series is packed with
full of learning
mixing the traditional as well as
advanced technology in place with the
Outlook of Consulting saying what to use
when to use
and what is the best way to use
I will be taking some of these sessions
there and I hope you will be
enjoying the session it will be a very
very
um learning inspiring sessions for all
of you
looking forward to see you in the class
thank you very much
thank you so much Dr kakar so does the
participant have any queries related to
the field if they can let us know in the
chat
and without further Ado let's also start
with the next part of today's webinar
I'd like to invite Dr Mohit mazumdar who
will also be the other program Mentor
for the chem informatics program he has
over 12 years of research and Industry
here in and he has completed a masters
in bioinformatics from Jamia Jamia milia
islamia and has a PHD in computational
biology and chemistry from jawaharlal
nehru University he is an expert in
machine learning and application to
biomedical and chemical data so without
further delay let's start with today's
session so the stage is all yours
uh thank you SRI gauri and thank you so
much Dr puneet for
giving us that clarity about how the
training program would be and why we
should be all excited about it because
it's a it's a time where technology is
evolving at a rapid play pace and uh at
the same time we are finding new things
new details and uh doing discoveries so
it's a great time to learn this and
start applying because the opportunities
are like that only where the industry is
providing the right kind of opportunity
if you have the right kind of skills and
experience
so um thank you again
um for joining today's session and uh
for uh I'm really excited here today to
meet with you all who are interested in
utilizing modern data analysis tools
learning and exploring the 2D
two-dimensional as well as the
three-dimensional space to find the
answers to the problems of drug
Discovery so um we have been discussing
the in the session that how
this training program would be so uh as
Dr paneer said correctly that it
involves the traditional are learning
about the basics learning about what all
technologies have been used so far in
drug Discovery and what are the case
studies where this success has happened
in this utilizing drug data-driven drug
Discovery so we will be exploring
uh techniques that will involve us to
utilize more uh both two-dimensional and
three-dimensional space so it's really
exciting to be able to do that and
develop such skill sets as well so um
about the entire process
um
so uh we will get to the questions also
um in this session so in this
presentation what will be covered in my
part of the presentation and uh we will
have we'll find time for for the to
address the question so please feel free
to put your questions in the chat and
we'll be able to address them uh in
between
so as I was telling you that the process
of drug Discovery it demands the
selection of disease as we all know
Target hypothesis so what would be the
Target and the hypothesis behind the
Target and searching for potential
compounds that is that would be helpful
for us to reduce the severity of the
disease to any extent right uh so these
are some of the very critical components
when we think about drug Discovery in
general and then there are different
stages in there so lead identification
is a stage preclinical trial is a stage
clinical trial is a stage and then one
one could say that pharmacogenomic
optimization is also a stage so what are
the different opportunities now and
challenges that the industry is facing
uh because when there is a uh like
opportunities and when there are
challenges you will find also the
opportunities there so one of the very
uh talked about uh discipline that you
might have been hearing or research
areas Precision medicine so personalized
medicine and why this program is a
modern data Discovery or data
drug Discovery program is because of
that because we are not only thinking
about drug Discovery as a traditional
way of looking at it but also a modern
way of looking at it why what what are
the different ways that we can enhance
and reduce the time as well as find
meaningful answers without getting fail
getting failed in that process so
Precision medicine drug design is an
exciting field drug repurposing is an
exciting field so in this presentation
we will learn about
the modern drug Discovery pipeline that
we've been discussing about the chem
informatics and data driven drug
Discovery the training part and the
project part uh thus uh the schedule of
the online training and the research how
are we going to do it what are the ways
one could register and what is the
sustainment sustainability cost for us
and also the advancements and the use of
Cutting Edge technology so from machine
learning deep learning to utilizing
um other
known data driven Technologies uh all
those options are there it would be it
would be based on the progress how you
progress and how you interact with us
and learn through this entire process so
um a little bit of introduction
um
so the drug Discovery program that we
have started which is the camera
informatics or biomedical drug Discovery
and this is the current version uh we
started this program into
2020 where we collaborated with the
Pharma industry and one of the
e associate partner of us to be able to
do this is the Faba Academy so Farber
Academy along with their mentors we
designed an uh part we first partnered
and then we designed topics and
curriculums and learning modules that
will be more relevant for the students
because it's driven from the industry
experts from the industry leaders from
the industry so the first course that we
did in 2000 uh 2020
included advisors from uh different uh
companies who have Rich background
working with large big Pharma and
biotechnology companies and now our
co-founders and Founders are working in
this space and you have already met Dr
puneet and you will also find video
presentations by Dr Ajit Kama Dr Uday
saxena and if we get an opportunity if
you start working on your own project
then we will have a discussion and we
will have them as also help you in this
entire learning and research training
program that we are just inviting all
you to join so that's about the
conceptualization and how all of this
has started it started with an industry
aspect and it focuses on the gaps that
are not uh being filled in the education
or other trainings that are available
so a little bit about
um the modern biomedical drug Discovery
Pipeline and how things have changed so
people who are learning drug Discovery
they know about docking they know they
have heard about simulations molecular
modeling Alpha fold and all but they
these are tools so before the tool I
think it's very much important to
understand that why we are doing this
what is the what is how we are doing
this is something that will come next
but why we are doing this and what all
we can do is very important to know so
that's why this omix logic training
program is a great opportunity because
you get to know not only from the drug
Discovery aspects but but from a genetic
or a more detailed uh like from a more
detailed data that will tell you that
why this the why there is a gene why
there is a mutation and why what has the
the what is the effect of that mutation
it will help you to find new targets so
genomics and biomedical data sets they
help us identify for example biomarkers
now there is a company called DNA Nexus
that just that focuses only on this like
genomic and biomedical data sets they
use and they identify biomarkers and
they focus on drug discovery
so another important Rich area to find
uh you know information to start your
work or to find something new is through
the scientific literature so scientific
articles to identify Target ID you know
there are large number of companies and
they just focuses on this that
identifying articles and the conference
presentations and from the value that
the academicians are generating and to
find the identify drug targets that are
relevant for the industry so
several companies work on that even in
India uh another aspect so tumor sample
data to identify prognostic biomarkers
so this is predictive oncology huge
application in oncology as for the known
reasons uh very complex disease and uh
very less recovery uh so a lot of uh
opportunities are there in terms of
digging the data finding the right kind
of Target and then targeting molecules
for that kind of Target
medical literature and symptoms symptom
drug data for drug repurposing so we've
been talking about drug repurposing also
so the drugs that have been already
approved if they are working for other
indications how do we know that what is
the method so there are companies like
helix who are focused just on that
cellular fluorescent Imaging data for
richer in vitro pharmacology so there is
a company called recursion that works on
that protein structural data to identify
peptide binders so there's a company
called maintain.ai that focuses on that
so protein structural data and compound
binding for small molecules with
generation atom wise is a company that
works on that so as I'm telling you that
like different disciplines so even a
micro discipline within a discipline is
enough for a company to you know work on
that finding different types of
uh ways to assist the drug Discovery
process so the opportunities are so much
in this space uh one would need a uh
understanding of how to work with the
data how to analyze and find meaningful
way to analyze the data so we've been
discussing about the application of
modern biomedical drug Discovery for
example in personalized medicine so
personalized or Precision medicine
initiating from Clinical and like for
example for from clinical data from from
molecular pharmacological data so it it
introduces a new era in healthcare and
it aims to identify and predict the
optimal treatment for a patient or for a
cohort
so this is also like uh earlier called
evidence-based medicine so
evidence-based medicine integrates
information uh which is which is what
you see in Vivo and which is what you
see in the observational studies which
is what you see in clinical trials up to
the meta-analysis for the clinical
consideration so
this is uh to understand the population
gen also like the average of the
population and uh there are many
companies who are intensively working on
this to understand the pharmacological
aspects and different aspects that could
help them in Noble uh drug Discovery
novel drug Discovery drug Delivery
Systems and also drug repurposing so
um the research This research will allow
us like will allow you to utilize both
experimental or clinical data so you you
have that understanding that how things
are working in in real world and then
design a project so many of us are come
from an academic background and many of
those projects are not translational in
aspect so one of the things that we are
trying to do here in atomics logic is to
work on translational problems so that's
a also an opportunity
now uh application like understanding
for example uh I this is just to
elaborate on that understanding that how
for example transcriptomics so
transcriptomics is to understand the
transcriptome which is the gene
expression patterns and uh how do we
find out things it's very simple like
when you compare so understanding the
consequences of an individual
transcriptomics variation a individual
means a patient uh which which differs
from any other patient so understanding
an individual's transcriptomics
variation is kind of fundamental today
to disappear the human biology and
disease because this data is something
that you need to look at to understand
and like gain all the insights that you
might require so gene expression
patterns in association with clinical
data can help identify molecular
biomarkers for Diagnostics and for
therapy selections so new discoveries
include a better understanding of these
complex diseases at a subcellular level
as well as Target identification for no
world drug targeting or drug designing
or repurposing so uh this multiomics
approach is the modern drug discovery
that uses you know from sequence to
structure from home mix insights to
understand the cellular
cellular interplay uh protein protein
complex interaction understanding the
entire uh you know
um environment which is the system
biology approach and then trying to
mimicking that environment which is
through molecular Dynamic simulation so
that's after that you have all the
computational tools in between you are
doing the discovery in between you're
trying to model and find the right kind
of complex which is also a difficult
task because there are so many small
consideration you have to make when you
are trying to mimic something within on
within an organism for example within a
host how the molecules are acting within
inside our body they are not stagnant
they are moving all the time there is
Dynamics involved so how do we able to
do predict that
and that and to predict them correctly
is a challenge so and that's why we are
here uh to as a mentor and we are
developed we have developed all these
sessions and uh materials and uh
utilizing the research which is ongoing
the current research and our own
experience to help guide students
achieve and learn these technologies
that will be really helpful in the
future and also now so uh from Target
Discovery we've been discussing about
Target Discovery so we discussed about
how different types of uh says clinical
samples cell line data cell model data
patient samples animal model data can
help us in that process of you know
Target identification then Target
validation and then go for drug
Discovery so this initial phase is
critically important if you are thinking
about an entire big project or if you
want to work on a small project also in
some of these Associated areas
now um about the training that we are
going to start the chem informatics for
biomedical drug Discovery has all those
aspects so quickly we will get to an
understanding of how the application of
machine learning algorithms are there
how the application of different types
of approaches are there we'll start with
an overview of that and then I'll tell
you about the sessions how the sessions
are planned and what will be what we
will be covering in the sessions and how
that translates into a independent
research or how that translates into
research
so um
one of the things that has happened uh
in the recent past and uh if if you guys
have any question feel free to write it
in the chat and during this presentation
um so uh I might maybe before I start
this section just take a look at the
questions if there are any
[Music]
um
how can one incorporate chem informatics
a dry lab process with animal study a
wet lab uh so as I'm in as I was telling
you that
what wet lab studies are doing are
helping is they are helping in
generating data any wetler experiment
will generate some data and once you
have that data it's a dry lab process so
it's all correlated you just have to
know that what kind of data you're
generating with dry bitlab experiments
if you know about if it is a cancer
related research and if you are
generating some data with that bitlab
experiments you can reach out to us and
we can discuss how that data can be
further you know how your even
experiments can be designed Based on
data so the approach has changed
completely now now we look at data first
and then we design experiments and
that's how we are cutting the cost
earlier we were doing virtual screening
with millions and millions of compounds
now it's knowledge driven we know that
okay this is the active group this is
how the molecule should look like these
are the different molecules that are
good binders so we go with information
and knowledge and then we go for a
specific X experiments so it is called
what it is help helping is in is that it
is helping in reducing the cost so much
like from these high throughput
experiments here when you're where
you're trying everything against
everything now you are very focused and
then the chances and the probability of
your success is also very high because
it's knowledge driven
there's a question so we are posting
these jobs on our own mix logic portal
also so we'll share that job listing and
you'll be able to see that in the portal
itself but uh we also have a LinkedIn
group where I share about these job
opportunities all the time like every
day
um so you'll find jobs there also and uh
like you can also search out so look for
yourself with these keywords and you'll
find jobs uh and postdoctoral
opportunities PhD opportunities even
Master scholarships and all of that
through this sort of training we have
students who have completed it and uh
they they have gone to do higher degrees
in very rapid universities through
recommendation and through the
experience
yeah I think our team member they
they've prayed our team members will be
able to yeah thank you shubham and
please help Dave preet
all right so now going back to the
second phase of this so I wanted to
discuss the application of machine
learning algorithms in different uh
aspects so in most drug Discovery
projects what happens is that the
protein is uh chosen as a drug Target
right for the development of
Therapeutics so that's how we know
things like so several supervised and
unsupervised machine learning approaches
have been used for structural prediction
at different levels of analysis so we
are first talking about structure
prediction so if you don't have a
structure which is
your drug Target how do we how do you
predict that structure so that is
something that comes first but if you
already have a cool crystallized or
structure predicted structure or uh
sorry experimental structure then
obviously there is a high probability
that
um because all the atoms have been
mapped with an experimental uh map which
has been generated through maybe
extractography or anima spectroscopy or
cryo em so these are experimental
methods and if you have a structure
which is uh derived experimentally then
the probability of all the atoms present
at that 3D space is very high so you get
like maybe you it you get better results
but then again uh when you're doing
modeling the structure that we get from
modeling is also very detailed we just
have to make sure that it's properly
modeled so some manual maneuver is
important and that's in that context you
look for uh Missing residues because
many times what happens in modeling is
that uh in crystallography there are
some regions where there is no electron
density so in that case you have to find
and build those areas so how to make
sure that those are stereochemically uh
uh physically uh like stable low energy
so all those considerations are
important when we are thinking about
um
um uh like predictions so in as I was
telling you that uh again like
predictions happen at different levels
so primary sequence of amino acids uh
then uh finding the secondary structure
from the primary uh structure analysis
from there a primary amino acids so from
you have 20 amino acids and your string
of uh them uh as a protein sequence then
you want to predict that how they are
going to fold so whether there will be
alphysis whether or there will be beta
sheets or there will be coil or Loops
how do that's a prediction that is uh it
that's how it starts from the secondary
structure prediction then the tertiary
structure prediction that how it is
going to fold in a three-dimensional uh
uh format form so the problem of protein
folding so you're trying to solve that
and then quaternally quaternary
structures and protein protein
structures how it is interacting with
other three dimensional structures and
how it happens what are the insights
that you can get so machine learning
algorithms are used for secondary
structure prediction solvent
accessibility prediction so what is the
solvent how many areas in the protein
where solvent can be accessible so your
solvent could be water also
so to find out through the groups and
all and then topology generation contact
map generation which finally integrates
this knowledge into building a 3D model
of the target so supervised machine
learning methods like svm and DT
algorithms they you they are used for
rule generation training data set for
secondary structure prediction
artificial neural network is used to
predict distances between the pair of
amino acid residues which is used to
contract construct the potential of mean
forces for generating protein shapes so
these are all published study that I'm
talking about and the Machine learning
methods are also used for fold
recognition and model evaluation
evaluation so then we have a molecular
or 3D building techniques or like the
algorithms that have been really used
from from very very beginning like
conjugate gradient gradient descent
model so the conjugate decent gradient
model is also used in
uh energy minimization Monte Carlo
methods are used in optimization energy
minimization as well as 3D model
building so these methods are uh these
algorithms or methods are like
traditional algorithms and now they are
working with the machine learning
algorithms so in model generation you
get to work with like different types of
algorithms then you have heard about
Alpha fold from deepmind then that
performed well and they created models
uh and they have now a database where
they have predicted all the models in
association with
embl so uh what are the different
limitations and all we will also learn
about that but like as you have learned
like have a now clear understanding I
guess of what is the application of
machine learning for primary sequence of
Target proteins now the second is ligand
molecule you could see that what are the
like ligand from how do we go like we
learned about one one thing which is
from
um structure to finding those Inhibitors
and molecules now from in from the other
approach uh for example I'll tell give
you this ligand molecule the others the
right side of the panel
so uh a single bio bioactive ligand can
be used as an input to search for a vast
set of similar compounds so you have a
you have known drug and it's a bioactive
drug and it's working really well now
you want to find similar compounds in
the chemical databases so machine
learning approaches such as kernel
discrimination and nave-based
um Bayesian classifier methods are used
for such virtual screening by analyzing
the property of the bioactive part so
similarly compounds are searched scored
and screened based on the distance based
similarity functional group matching
with the bioactive input bioactive
compound and then that distance based
approach as well so this includes like
you know chemical fingerprinting
functional group like a shape
pharmacophore and all of that
so this is an overview of all the things
that are happening and advancements and
uh integration of the methods that have
been used such as uh for ligand-based
searching now we will learn little bit
about the other two ways which is like
de novo design of molecules with desired
property so this is also a very hot
topic uh and it's being used by some of
the AI based companies such as in silico
medicine to generate molecules of
desired properties so computational
approaches can be used to generate
chemical molecules as well with desired
physiochemical and biological properties
so supervised machine learning
algorithms are used for training the
model to generate chemically feasible
Smiley strings so smile is a format to
generate or to write
chemical structures and also for
accessing the biological property of the
compound so there's a process there's a
there's a deep learning method called
reinforcement learning for structural
evaluation which is a deep enforced
reinforcement learning based method and
also there are graph theories which are
used for all of this so this is this was
a brief overview of the advancement that
one could use but uh for those who are
starting and those four who are
beginners obviously uh we will not go to
the advanced steps just like that so in
this training program we will cover from
a very basic like we are very beginner
level where we have started where I have
started understanding what are the basic
things and how to understand and relate
from this basic understanding two
different stages like from basic to 2D
space to 3D space and then machine
learning deep learning
molecular Dynamics all of that so it's
an exciting Journey it's uh and very uh
visual because we will be doing Hands-On
uh in throughout the throughout the
training program because it's mostly
Hands-On and very less theoretical in
aspect because uh Theory you can always
read and learn from research
Publications and Google so um here uh we
will start with as I was telling you
that we will start with very Basics like
protein structures are very important
because they interact and they
communicate and there is chance that
there is there are targets so uh protein
protein interactions to how the how to
do molecular visualization and molecular
visualization is very important of for
chem informatics or for drug Discovery
so all of you who would be joining the
program will be learning about different
molecular visualization tools and how to
utilize them
then we will go into chem informatics
first we learn about the macromolecules
and then we learn about the small
molecules and uh how to explore the
chemical space like databases uh prepare
for virtual screening large databases
how to utilize them for drug Target
identification or for searching similar
ligands those are the key things and
then key businesses so there is always a
business component or industry component
associated with our training here so
then the focus is to go into those
databases explore those databases learn
about accessing those databases and
curate bioactive molecules and find the
right kind of molecules so that could be
specific for example kinase Inhibitors
or you're looking at very specific type
of Inhibitors with a specific type of
biochemical or physiochemical properties
so in this we will be again the Hands-On
part is there where we will learning
about the softwares tools which are
freely available for you to utilize and
use them along with the mentor or after
the mentor session and practice on your
own because we will be also providing
the recorded session and the content and
the material and the links in a
systematic manner so that you learn from
the basic and even if you miss some of
the sessions you can go back and you
will have it all with you to learn and
do it anytime you wish to but to it's
advisable to go along with the sessions
so that the desired outcome can be you
can get the desired outcome within that
time space
now uh exploring the protein Data Bank
um the protein Data Bank is a is is uh I
think is the cradle for structural
biology and for drug Discovery
structure-based drug Discovery so here
you we find all the experimental
structures and uh you can see that as
many as 60 000 structures are available
for humans and uh the uh the the list
goes on so we have a lot of structures
now compared to the previously and you
can see the number of structures that
are deposited and how they have grown
over the time and uh different like for
example SARS go to just in a few years
like three years there are more than uh
almost 3000 structures which is massive
in in understanding about a virus as
small as Sasuke 2 and having so much
structural information so just imagine
uh if you can understand the system
biology from that how many opportunities
are there to help so uh yeah I mean this
is the repository where we will be
finding the structures and understanding
the very basics of structure wow how to
understand the structure how to and
change something in there how to
incorporate mutations how to understand
the role of the mutations
and exploring different types of
research projects and structures so here
the participants will be joining they'll
be they they'll they'll have the
opportunity to explore the
three-dimensional space and find their
own structure of Interest disease of
interest and work with that structure to
further investigate and find out how
they are folding how they are maybe
functioning what are the key residues
where to find the active site what are
the solvent accessibility areas if there
is an allostatic site or a conventional
drug Discovery will work what are the
different types of drug Discovery
approaches one could take whether it is
a flex or whether it is uh what kind of
docking are we going to talk about what
kind of simulation so all those things
are possible
so we will elaborate on each of these
sessions for example Target structure
prediction I have already discussed a
lot about it so let's now so we'll not
discuss it further but these are will be
discussed in the context of a case study
so where we will be covering uh these
different topics and then we will be
working in that demonstration section in
the uh session during the session so
different types of modeling what are the
different uh techno technologies that
are used for the different tools that
are used what are the pros and cons of
using one before another and what are
the most popular and validated methods
that are out there
then Target identification and virtual
screening so virtual screening is again
very important in that drug Discovery
aspect because it's uh it's being used
so prashanjit has a question which
software do I need to install on my Mac
so for molecular visualization prosenjit
you can download Chimera or Pi Mall uh
Chimera is free and a very powerful tool
pymol is propriety but also for academic
there are free versions which are
available so I I think you can start
from there and have a molecular
visualization tool for sure installed in
your software in your MacBook to start
with so now about virtual screening as I
was telling you that virtual screening
so let's simplify this so virtual
screening aim aims to computationally
search the universe of potentially
organic molecules to identify a
manageable number of virtual hits right
so what it is doing is that it is
searching for molecule molecules which
could be considered as hits so
identifying them in the context of you
know how the initial screening could be
done so one such computational method
which we use for virtual screening is
docking right molecular docking so it is
used uh it uses the three-dimensional
structure of the target protein and
places small molecules Into The Binding
site so that is however a
computationally complexity a
computational complexity which is there
in docking
the evalu the evaluation of each small
molecules require consideration of its
low energy three-dimensional
conformation so this is what I was
telling you about before that uh when we
are doing uh virtual screening when we
are starting from virtual screening
there are different steps so one is
virtual screening another is then
intensive uh docking which is where it
is Computing all the different
parameters which are also important
which is not done at the screening stage
because screening you have a large large
Library
so generating low conformational three
day three-dimensional uh calculating the
energy of that conformation is not
possible at that point of time so uh we
have tools which do that uh and help us
screen from larger library to smaller
libraries but obviously what is the best
approach in bioinformatics for me is to
utilize multiple tools and then uh come
up with a table which has uh the top uh
top scorers from each of those tools so
that in a way in within bioinformatics
validates are work
so that will be covered in the fifth
session and then we will learn about the
different uh steps and we have some
projects that we have already worked on
for example this is a drug Discovery
project that company has worked on with
Roseville Park Cancer Institute which we
will be using as a case study
and then we have the actual session on
the other aspect after virtual screening
the in-depth screen docking and stages
of drug Discovery process so we will
learn about the pharmacological aspect
and Drug Discovery aspect and the
different conformation uh using the top
softwares which are freely available but
also the concepts are like the logic is
same the software might vary but once
you know the logic once you know how to
utilize it what are the different
aspects I think the language Remains the
Same so it's important to understand the
basics and also the parameters that you
have to look into when you're looking
into these different aspects so one of
such experiments if you do with us you
will be able to explore on your own and
also we'll be able to help you in case
you use different softwares of your own
interest
so uh uh we in till the sixth session as
you could see we are learning about the
basics and we are learning from a very
beginner aspect to those to to for those
who are learning for the first time or
who want to learn from the very
beginning and basic level to that once
level I think first to say first to six
sessions are to help them uh reach at
that stage and then we go into more
advanced topics such as data science and
AI in healthcare chem informatics using
R uh these such these such topics so in
in this aspect I would like to talk a
little bit about qsir so qsr or qspr
these are uh based on uh the idea that
the structure of a molecule might
influence its physical chemical and
biological Behavior so we have been
using by the way qsr for last 40 years
in the practice of Agro chemistry
pharmaceutical chemistry toxicology and
many other assets of chemistry so qusr
has effectively modeled many
physiochemical properties such as
toxicity metabolism interaction between
drugs carcinogenesis so initial qsr
model such as hanche and Free Wilson
analysis very popular I guess
uses uh that use regression models to
relate potency and structural and
chemical properties such as chelation
substitution patterns surface activity
hydrophobicity Solutions sorry
solubility
electronic forces electrostatic forces
so
so in the context of the overall
protocol for constructing qsr model for
drug designing has been systematized and
many open source tools and softwares are
available uh for uh such steps to con
which are con which consists of several
modular steps for chemoinformatics and
machine learning techniques so in qsrs
uh in qsr modeling you start with
molecular encoding in which uh in which
the chemical structure of the drug
molecule is used to derive the chemical
features and the property and then you
go on and work on that so uh there is an
opportunity for those who want to learn
about this in the advanced modules that
we have prepared followed by the case
study so we have a case study which is
the discovery of c0t nip kinase
inhibitor for lung cancer and also
there's a blockbuster drug that recently
got
um
uh there's a company uh that was
recently got acquired by BMS uh BMS is a
Bristol miles uh it's a very big Pharma
company for 4.1 billion dollars
so and it's a it's a inhibitor it's a
kinase inhibitor and uh it works uh it
works on different uh uh chemotherapies
um treatment so I think I mean that's
that's some of those case studies are
really helpful for understanding that uh
what are the success stories and uh also
uh what are the different ways these uh
companies I have utilized
um to reach at that stage
so I mean tools and softwares uh here's
a list from Auto Doc to molecular
docking to Aven issue modeling so we
will be able to utilize uh many of these
for the understanding unless there are
propriety which is like Desmond
Schrodinger or Charm so other than that
the ones that are available we will be
able to use for the project work if you
have a hypothesis if you have a
structure that you have started working
with or if you have a disease type that
you are working on so those who are
would be joining so we have different
modes of joining the program so
um one could choose to join between for
one month or three months so for three
months we will be able to work on
Research proposals and then we also have
the research fellowship program which
actually helps students to complete a
research project so
um then as I was telling you that this
entire Discovery is focused drug
Discovery is focused on the modern
approach so you can work on oncology
related projects you can work on
infectious disease related projects and
you can use multiple types of data types
to be able to come to the drug Discovery
or drug Target or you can use several
other approaches that we can work with
so it's up to you and it's also uh you
will be also learning about these
approaches if you have not uh if you
think that you're new to all of this and
you're not ready for it so that's why
the beginner level is there so that you
are ready for all of this so again here
the focus is AI in molecular drug
Discovery we discussed about artificial
intelligence playing a role and also
deep learning has a huge role so we will
discuss all those aspects in this
session and then understanding that uh
from the point of view of how these
different Technologies so Google has
Deep Mind program has the open AI
program with uh
so incorporating the new technologies
that real like really impactful
technologies that are came into 2023
2022 so I don't think there are any
other programs which utilizes that but
this is what we've been doing we are
updating it like every month every week
and so that we can enable uh those who
are joining to get to the latest
Technologies learn about the latest
advancements and apply them into their
research so uh this will include like
understanding and this would include
like Pharma and bioinformatics Industry
uh integration this will include like
different types of softwares for
molecular visualization this will
include Advanced chem informatics which
is to further manipulate the structures
this will include the research projects
that I've been discussing about and this
will include Integra question of omics
data in the search projects if that is
what your direction is it will include
you to work on Pharma projects which is
for specific Pharma problems it will
include uh for you to work on different
infectious disease projects that are
there for example SARS Cove 2 and
learning about different uh binding
properties we have already published
articles on malaria vaccine design and
resistance using popular population
genetics and Drug Discovery and
molecular Dynamics on all of that so in
the end we have a case study which is on
successful as well as the frailed drug
development to give you an insight about
how what worked and what has not worked
this is a recent publication that we
were able to complete
through this training and it's an
infectious disease genomics research
which was recently published in
molecules so I think that concludes my
presentation station for today and we
have still the registration and the cost
and the scholarships and really exciting
time because we have a really great
scholarship model which is just
available for next for few days which is
I think what Spurs will be talking about
I'll look into the questions and uh I'll
meanwhile I'll also invite sparsh to
discuss about the registration and
through those address any questions I'll
I'm checking in the chat
thank you so much
yes
oh thank you
so let me share my screen
uh so could you please confirm if you
can see my screen
perfect thank you
um so uh hi my name is and I'm the
marketing manager here at Pine biotech
so I'll quickly guide you all through
the registration process uh process of
this particular program named chem
informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
so this is the program page and the
program is going to commence from 27th
Jan and in between we'll be having one
more a webinar which would be related to
a Hands-On session so we'll be uh
telling you about that particular
webinar in a short while we'll be
sending you invitation about it so when
I'll scroll down
um about the program overview the
curriculum Etc Dr Mohit has already uh
explained it in a very comprehensive and
extensive way so I'll directly jump on
to the registration process the
resources costing and the scholarship
part
so here you all can see there are three
different tenures uh in which one could
enroll for so there are some of the
resources common in all the three
tenures that are online tutorials that
you will be having access to the omics
logic learn portal which have more than
32 plus courses on different domains in
area of analysis then we have more than
16 plus example research projects again
on different uh ARF analysis and domain
plus case studies then you will have
access to the project examples the
coding sessions the session recordings
online Mentor Support Online technical
support certification of completion and
example Cloud pipelines on T bioinfo
server so these are the common resources
which one would have access to if
they'll enroll in any of the tenure now
what is the difference between the three
ten years in 45 days you will be getting
a full-fledged training you will be
trained related to drug Discovery chem
informatics you'll be taught different
software tool databases Etc
in 60 days tenure you have two different
opportunities so the first 45 days would
be devoted to your training part and the
next 15 days you will be devoted to how
you can draft a research proposal
presented to the mentor so that the
mentor can evaluate your research
proposal and guide you the changes or
any Amendment which would make your
research proposal more validated and
further you can work on your independent
research project also one second is the
you will have access to one-on-one
Mentor sessions so for example if you
are going through any training module
and you get stuck somewhere and you want
to meet mental one-on-one so we can fix
an exploratory call of your with the
mentor of around 15 to 20 minutes and
you can clarify each and every question
now the outcome for 60 days is a poster
presentation it could be in a omics
research Symposium or any other research
Symposium it could be in any
International Conference also now in 90
days you again have two different
opportunities first is one-on-one Mentor
sessions obviously and second is the
first 45 days would be devoted to your
training part and the next 45 days would
be devoted to you how you can develop
your independent research project
and that particular project would be
further publishable in a good
peer-reviewed Journal so the outcome
comes to be a research publication and
also a poster presentation so these this
uh this was the difference between the
three tenures so now you can see here on
my screen uh the pricing is in USD and
uh you can definitely change the pricing
according to your location so here
there is a drop down menu and in this
drop down menu there are different
currencies mentioned according to
different locations uh now if I click on
USD and I'll scroll down I can see the
pricing in USD for 45 days it's 150 for
60 days it's dollar 300 and for 90 days
it's dollar 450. and now uh till January
15 we are providing each and every
interested participant with a 50 person
scholarship and uh one of our
representative will uh
publish or will uh tell you the steps of
registering and will also tell you about
the coupon code which is chem 50
c-h-e-m chem is in capitals and five
zero I'll just tell you how you can
proceed further with the payment
checkout process also now for those who
are in India so the pricing is in INR
and when you'll scroll down you can see
that for 45 days the pricing is 7500
then for 60 days it's 10 000 and for 90
days it's fifteen thousand and likewise
you can change the currency depending
upon your location and see the pricing
or the fee for the program accordingly
now moving further
telling you about the payment procedure
so for example if I'm interested in 45
days tenure I'll click on the buy now
button
after clicking on buy now button I'll be
redirected to the omics logic checkout
page so I'll just quickly write type
here the coupon code that is scam 50.
click on apply and here you can see that
the coupon is applied successfully
message will pop out you will need to
fill out your user details like your
name your email your phone number your
country occupation organization Etc
click on this check box and select the
payment mode if you want to pay it via
stripe PayPal Etc now those who are
unable to pay via PayPal or stripe we
have alternative payment methods also
and for that you can
uh write us at marketing omicslogic.com
or you can ping us at the official
number that is plus nine one nine eight
seven six one three four one two zero
and we'll guide you with the alternative
payment methods also so this was about
the registration process the scholarship
and uh the fee so if anyone is having
any doubt related to the registration
process Etc uh please feel free to
unmute yourself and ask or please feel
free to write in the chat box and I'll
be there to SS and guide you thank you
so SRI gauri has already shared my
details uh so the marketing uh so email
ID is marketing logic.com and the
contact is
9876-134120 this contact number is app
is active on WhatsApp also so those who
want to connect me connect with me via
WhatsApp or have one-on-one conversation
via WhatsApp call that is also
applicable the coupon code again is chem
50 expiration of the coupon code is on
January 15th so please uh hurry up and
Avail the opportunity
if anyone is having any doubts so please
feel free to write in the chat box over
to you SRI body thank you
thank you so much sparsh so we will
pause for a couple of seconds if the
participants have any queries
um you can either unmute yourself and
ask or put your query in the chat
otherwise we'll be ending with today's
webinar
foreign
is asking what software do we need for
Hands-On training
yeah so to address that uh prashanjit
you can start with the molecular
visualization software and then we will
be sharing throughout the program
um the tutorials you would need to
install the softwares that would be
needed but many of the softwares are
available uh online so the web servers
will take care of that so you'll not
have to install a lot of softwares but
those softwares which would require
which requires high computational power
those will be required to install and
you can start with the molecular
visualization softwares and then we will
share with you as you join the program
once you join the program we will share
with you the detailed tutorials
thank you so much sir uh sparsh there's
a query for you that is uh from tanmoi
are there any discounts for BSC level
students
[Music]
so yes we are giving right now a 50
discount to everyone for every level of
Education
thank you so much parsh and um
can you recommend few free software for
molecular talking
yeah you can write an email to me or our
team team members or connect with our
team members and we'll share your share
with you over an email the free
softwares that you can start exploring
with
thank you sir and we have another query
from Muhammad Noor does your platform
provide online software or any
interactive practice
we will be using open source softwares
and the platform has a structural
biology section where that could be
utilized for molecular screening
thank you sir
so if participants have no further
queries we'll be ending today's meeting
so have a great day and we look forward
to seeing you at the program thank you
everyone
thank you
thank you everyone